tankred stöbe ist bei uns wir steigen
gleich nochmal nach peking gestalten
heute quer durch die welt tübingen
peking egal
aber wenn sie das hören als arzt auch
als jemand der überall in der welt
unterwegs ist also macht nicht wirklich
hoffnung ich fand das war eine sehr
realistische einschätzung der dinge
die habe ich so von politischer seite
noch nicht gehört ich überlege jubel
trubel heiterkeit über diese impfung und
das zweite ist die frage nach diesem
studiendesign wie läuft das denn in
afrika in lateinamerika sie sind doch
oft vor ort wie geht das also ist
tatsächlich hoch spannende moment das
ist ja fast wie so ein live krimi den
wir erleben ja ich denke manchmal wieso
die eroberung des südpols erde wo wir es
konnten monate lang rechts hatten und
jetzt geht es wieder um stunden und tage
und das ist natürlich erst mal und ich
glaube dass das darf ich auch als
humanitärer art sage nein ein toller
durchbruch wenn es dann jetzt im stoff
gibt aber nach dieser freude gibt es
eben sofort ganz ganz viele fragen die
ihnen noch nicht beantwortet sind ein
paar bands gerade schon auch an sie
adressiert es gibt natürlich weiteren
zum beispiel auch erleben wir mehr und
mehr auch in ländern vor allem auch in
afrika wenn dann dort pharma studien
aufgelegt werden dass die menschen da
sehr sensibilisiert werden und sagen wir
wollen nicht die versuchskaninchen sein
das ist der heutige vorwurf den man hört
genau wie afrikaner wollen nicht das
versuchskaninchen für euch europäer oder
amerikaner seien auf der anderen seite
ist es eben auch so dass wir wenn wir
jetzt in ruhe anschauen wenn wir an der
erkrankung an gucken wir kennen ja auch
nur oder es ist ja nun möglich dauert
auch forschung zu betreiben wo das wurde
das krankheitsbild vorhandene ist schon
wieder nicht eine ebola studien
deutschland machen wo wir aber diese
ethische konflikte um dienstag gerade
ging also bitte mir soll wirklich keiner
erzählen dafür bin ich auch zu viel
unterwegs gewesen auch in afrika zum
beispiel wir soll doch keiner erzählen
damit meine ich ja sicher ein kremser
sondern ganz prinzipiell so naiv bin ich
nicht dass ich glaube dass wir nur
getrieben von von von moral und guten
ethischen vorsätzen durch die welt
laufen sollte es geht am ende um harte
dollar was denn sonst
und das wären weiter großer punkte also
ja ich sage mal big pharma die sind
jetzt nicht mehr der kommunikation
altruistisch aber dann darf auch nicht
ja
und unsere eine unserer größten sorgen
jetzt als humanitäre helfer ist eben die
dass wir sobald es einen impfstoff gibt
der dann auf markt ist dann fangen
natürlich die verteilungskämpfe an
und dann werden ganz klar die länder
runterfallen die vielleicht jetzt auch
eben dort als studienorte zur verfügung
sich stellen und da sieht man dann schon
auch die ungerechtigkeit und da ist eben
unser dringender appell wir können nicht
mit impfstoffen die sie haben es erwähnt
öffentlich gefördert wurden mit mit
vielen millionen euro real music hall wo
die welt nehmen wir haben eine eine
pandemie die jedes land betrifft die
ganze welt noch nie waren wir glaube ich
so vereint in einem thema wie in diesen
monaten
und dann darf es nicht sein wenn dann
ein impfstoff verfügbar ist dass der
dann wirklich nur in den reichen ländern
verfügbar und verknüpft werden kann
sondern da muss von vornherein und da
ist wirklich genauso den dringlichkeit
auch wie jetzt eine marktreife eines
impfstoffs dass wir jetzt klar liegen
klar und auch eine deutsche regierung
prozentual von dem was wir schon gekauft
haben diese impfdosen die wir schon
reserviert haben
davon geben wir auch was ab für länder
wo klar ist die könnte ich das nie
leisten für frontlinien schnell vergeht
als dort anwenden
das ist ein brutaler darwinismus dem wir
dann beobachten können ist doch gar
keine frage das haben wir auch immer
wieder erlebt also wenn wir wenn wir hiv
aids denken da haben
aids kranke in afrika haben zehn jahre
warten müssen bis sie die impfstoffe und
bzw die medikamente bekommen konnten die
es hier im norden schon gab also die
erfahrung ich musste fast umgekehrt
sagen sie ist keine medikamente oder
impfstoffe entwicklung bekannt wo das
wirklich jetzt mal global ethisch so
abgelaufen ist dass man sagt das war ein
fairer deal
dafür ist auch technisch wäre wäre ich
also ich bin sehr gespannt
es gibt gute verlautbarungen jetzt was
was den crooner impfstoff angeht aber ob
es sich wirklich dann auch so
herausstellt das sind die ganz ganz groß
jeder geht anders damit um und es wird
spannend zu sagen wir schalten jetzt so
ulf röller der hoffentlich uns
vielleicht auch gehört hat ulf schirmer
nach peking
ich weiß nicht ob du die diskussion
gerade verfolgen konnte ist eigentlich
wollten wir ein ganz anderes thema
sprechen dann wird das trotzdem jetzt
machen wir gleich noch aber kurz einmal
mit dir über dieses thema reden also
lese gerade china liefert sensationelle
wirtschaftsdaten die einzige das einzige
land der welt das wirklich ein richtig
beeindruckendes wachstum hinlegen wird
in diesem jahr also unter diesen
bedingungen das heißt die chinesen
kommen da unglaublich gut wieder raus
die kanzlerin werden wir gleich hören
die sich sorgen macht genau deshalb die
diesbezüglich eine sehr klare ansage
gemacht hat und das heißt da geht es um
knüppelharte wirtschaftliche interessen
wie macht eine diktatur wie machen die
chinesen das wird er einfach per ordre
de mufti angesagt so du jetzt mit kommen
dann wirst du geimpft oder wie läuft das
also es wird schon massiv geimpft seit
einigen wochen und es werden viele
hunderttausende sind schon geimpft da
gibt es auch eine relativ transparentes
verfahren es geht vor allem um leute die
ins ausland gehen müssen weil nach der
offiziellen staatspropaganda in china
ist ja das virus im land endgültig
besiegt oder sehr großes unheil besiegt
und es geht ja darum dass die menschen
die ins ausland gehen chinesen eben
jetzt wollen dass sie sich dort schützen
und deswegen werden leute aus militär
geimpftes werden viele chinesen dämpft
die geschäftliche ins ausland gehen und
eben auch viele die im ausland studieren
wollen was man nicht weiß ist
die effizient und wie wirksam dieser
impfstoff ist man weiß auch nicht ob es
irgendwelche nebenwirkungen gibt wir
haben an einem impfzentrum gedreht mit
mit leuten die da als schlange gestanden
haben um die impfung zu bekommen man
bewirbt sich einfach auf einer webseite
und wenn man die kriterien erfüllt
bekommt man den und auf die frage haben
sie dann angst dass dieser impfstoff
vielleicht nicht genügend untersucht
worden ist bekommt man eine sehr
chinesische antwort nämlich der staat
sagt dass der impfstoff gutes dann wird
das auch so sein
wow und wie skat im hintergrund leeres
büro ist schon quasi frühen morgen über
die er in china oder in peking
dank der sehr dass uns noch zur
verfügung steht wir wollten kurz mit ihr
sprechen über den auftritt des deutschen
geologen alexander kekulé im
staatsfernsehen
wann hast du davon erfahren und hast du
das gesehen
im chinesischen staatsfernsehen ja da
muss sagen die land show ist jetzt in
china bekannt und hat quasi ihre
zuschauerzahl angesichts der 1,4
milliarden menschen die es gibt hier
vervielfacht dramatischen schilderung
mitbekommen es gibt diesen auslands
diesen auslandssender von china der auf
englisch quasi staatspropaganda sendet
und da war das dann ein gefundenes
fressen dann ist ein bisschen in die
richtung ging auch so wie man es
geschnitten hat dass man einen eindruck
haben könnte dass ein führender
deutscher virologin einer führenden
deutschen talkshow mehr der weniger
china von seiner schuld frei gesprochen
hat und genau das wollen die chinesen
und deswegen haben sie das benutzt wir
haben das mitbekommen gar nicht
unbedingt bei wir das stück gesehen
haben in dem staatssender sondern weil
das was sofort passiert wenn etwas von
der staatspropaganda vervielfältigt
werden soll geht das sofort in den
sozialen medien hoch wird unterstützt
dann gibt es auch leute die das positiv
kommentieren teilweise auch im sinne des
staates und dann potenziert sich das und
wird eine riesenwelle
also es ist eine sache die die chinesen
gerne aufgenommen haben sie haben es
natürlich unvollständig gebracht so dass
es ihrer sage ich mal propaganda genau
passt genau
und weil du das gerade ansprichst wir
schauen einmal kurz rein
wie die chinesen das gemachter welchen
teil sie aus der sendung hier genommen
haben und danach schauen wir mal an wie
es wirklich war
ist die wir heute zu sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit wissen auch
infektiöser als die ursprüngliche
variante und das virus was jetzt
weltweit überall festgestellt wird ist
das was in norditalien sich verbreitet
hat also dort war im grunde genommen
der startschuss für die weltweite
pandemie nicht in buchen
also was verfängt dann auch keiner fragt
man nach keine ordner dass mal ein
keiner kennt den kontext des funk oder
wurde das in frage gestellt man muss 1
verstehen
ich glaube schon dass die mehrheit der
chinesen auch wenn es natürlich keine
unabhängigen untersuchung umfragen gibt
sehr stolz darauf ist wie sie mit der
ganzen corona krise umgegangen sind sie
haben wirklich sehr sehr gute zahlen
es sieht wirklich so aus als sei das
land doch zu weiten teilen corona frei
oder wenigstens ganz niedrige zahlen
man kann sich natürlich mit maske
überall wird fieber gemessen
überall muss man seine gesundheits app
zeigen aber mit diesen kontrollmaßnahmen
kann man sich komplett frei bewegen wir
können auch durch das land fliegen und
das zeigt natürlich im vergleich zu
amerika oder auch europa das genau das
was die chinesische regierung sagen will
wir sind besser als die andern unser
system ist erfolgreicher gewesen
bei dieser bekämpfung der pandemie und
deswegen verfängt natürlich eine solche
aussage sehr weil die chinesen und der
vor allem den machthabern in china ist
gelungen ist diesen corona triumph quasi
zu einer patriotischen sache zwar genau
das einzige kleine problem dabei ist der
arme herr kekulé hat es so überhaupt
nicht gesagt und gezeigt einfach noch
mal den ganzen ausschnitt um zu
verstehen was eigentlich dieses gespräch
war was der inhalt dieses gesprächs war
schreibt zu dieser pandemie an den satz
der aufhorchen lässt zitiere das virus
das gerade weltweit grassiert ist nicht
das virus aus wo hahn
es ist das virus aus norditalien piccoli
dieser satz hat ich habe nochmal noch
mal gelesen und dachte was meinen sie
damit
ja woher wissen sie das es ist so dass
das virus was weltweit zirkuliert eine
variante ist die eigentlich erst in
norditalien aufgetreten ist dass das
nennen wir die gewandte das hat sich
genetisch verändert und ist wie wir
heute zu sehr hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
wissen auch infektiöser als die
ursprüngliche variante und das virus was
jetzt weltweit überall festgestellt wird
ist das was in norditalien sich
verbreitet hat also dort war im grunde
genommen
der startschuss für die weltweite
pandemie nicht in rohan und heute die
fälle die wir in china jetzt haben sie
den reimporte dieses italienischen virus
ich meine das klingt plausibel was sie
sagen aber es klingt exakt das was die
chinesische staatspropaganda habe ich
nicht dort abgeschrieben aber haben sie
was mit denen zu tun nicht wirklich
nicht herkommen keine alleine natürlich
nicht ich habe auch keine aktien an den
chinesischen firmen
dies ist so dann gerecht wenn sie das
sagen sowie die staatspropaganda das
sagt ist natürlich was anderes aber das
virus kommt ursprünglich natürlich schon
natürlich haben chinas wurde aus china
nach italien importiert hat sich dort
verändert das hat sich von norditalien
dann in die usa verbreitet
nach europa natürlich nach tirol und so
weiter aber das ist alles die variante
die in norditalien zum ersten mal
aufgetreten ist also in dem kontext ist
es natürlich eine völlig andere
geschichte
haben wir damit richtig gestellt was
wird in china eigentlich erzählt was ist
sozusagen das narrativ dass dort
mittlerweile etabliert wird ich lese
immer wieder von tiefgefrorenen shrimps
aus ecuador und von anderen
tiefkühlprodukten von sonst vorher was
sozusagen ist der versuch welche
erzählungen wird er etabliert also das
ist eigentlich ganz interessant die
chinesen sind unheimlich sensibel wenn
die welt auf sie mit dem finger zeigt
auch wegen der anfangsphase und wohin wo
eindeutig klar ist dass die chinesischen
behörden den ausbruch des virus anfang
januar verschleiert haben
sie haben sich wahnsinnig aufgeregt die
chinesen als donald trump immer vom
china virus gesprochen hat das fanden
sie unfair aber gleichzeitig haben sie
kein problem die korona virus quasi für
ihre zwecke zu instrumentalisieren zu
politisieren jetzt ist die lesart der
chinesen
wir sind herausragend und die gefahr
droht nur aus dem ausland das geht so
weit dass schweine haxen dass man dort
angeblich viren gefunden hat und sich
dort arbeiter dann als sie nach china
importiert worden sind angesteckt haben
und infiziert haben und wenn man danach
fragt oder versucht dafür eine
wissenschaftlichen beweis zu bekommen
kommt man nicht wirklich weiter also was
den chinesen ganz klar der bevölkerung
deutlich gemacht werden will
der sieg über das corona virus wenn er
so ist ist ein beleg dafür dass das
autoritäre system in china überlegen ist
die sind demokratischen systemen im
westen was immer demokratie steht immer
für die chinesischen machthaber für
chaos und für durcheinander und deswegen
wollen sie ihren leuten sagen bleibt uns
treu dann seid ihr sicher
dann bleibt gesund und ihr seht ja auch
die wirtschaft läuft auch noch besser
und ich danke dir sehr herzlich hoffe
sehr dass wir uns mal hier in diesem
studio sehen
ich hatte tausend fragen an dichte ich
die irgendwann mal hier in diesem studio
stellen möchte
herzlichen dank nach peking und gute
nacht
alles gute vielen dank
wow wenn man das so sieht man die
chinesen wie sie damit umgehen haben die
leute auch in ihrer partei die sagen ihr
müsst mal aufhören mit diesem mit diesem
laschen lockdown mit diesem auf und ab
und immer wieder ein bisschen aber nie
so richtig wir müssen jetzt mal richtig
richtig rein geräten das geht so nicht
weiter
sieh dir an was die chinesen machen also
bei der korona app schon die ist ja
faktisch nutzlos gestern abend über das
thema gesprochen die praktisch nutzlos
haben sie gerade gesagt faktisch ja ist
jetzt ein bisschen zugespitzt formuliert
weil ich weiß nicht wann und wo sich
sich sieht das jeder der cdu so dass das
ihre privatmeinung ist meine private
meinung da müssen sie die analyse die
csu dass ich komme ja gar nicht dass
ihre frage zu behandeln
wir wissen darum ist untersagt sich das
heißt dann nicht dieses nutzlos sondern
faktisch nutzlos aber ich muss natürlich
wissen wann und wo ich mich infiziert
habe damit die nachverfolgung beginnen
kann
die debatte gibt es aber china ist
natürlich war im letzten jahr mit einer
kleinen delegation auch da das ist
natürlich ein kompletter
überwachungsstaat wir haben wir eine
firma besuch zu einem gesichtserkennungs
firma da sind wir da reingegangen den
raum und dann haben die mal eben auf
eine ampel geschaltet haben sich eine
person rausgezogen und zack verglichen
mit dem internet man hatte sofort daten
wie alt ist die person und so weiter das
heißt das ist ein kompletter
überwachungsstaat den wollen wir nicht
haben dass keiner mittlerweile auch ohne
gesicht es geht auch sozusagen menschen
einfach nur am gang zu erkennen waren
sie identifizieren also wenn die mütter
hatten wir etwas gepflegt was auch immer
mit 1,3 sekunden wissen bescheid
deswegen kann es sein dass wir uns in
zehn jahren hier treffen wir nicht in
den rückspiegel schauen und sagen das
war ein game changer sozusagen was jetzt
passiert mit corona dann machen die den
riesen freihandelsabkommen ich meine wir
sind hier mit corona und apps
beschäftigt und die machen wir eben für
zwei milliarden menschen wenn man eben
die zelle abgeschafft die
dienstleistungen gehen runter in bezug
auf handelshemmnisse neben australien
mit dabei die medien japan china und wir
beschäftigen und ziel mit deswegen
müssen wir echt höllisch aufpassen china
ist kein entwicklungsland mehr
und dann ist ein knallharter konkurrent
ja dass wir diese themen auch
debattieren neben corona so das passt
jetzt perfekt frau gaben auch an sie
besondere aufmerksamkeit
die kanzlerin hat sich gestern auf dem
digital gipfel so dazu geäußert und wenn
man das wird dann klingt auch eine
gehörige portion frust mit schauen sie
mal eben schnell von souveränität aber
den die das kapital zu haben um wirklich
diese diese investitionen dann auch
tätigen zu können um diese autonomie
oder souveränität zu erlangen dass da
sind wir ein ganzes stück weg wir haben
jetzt wie gesagt sondern gemeinsames
mikroelektronik projekt in europa
aufgelegt aber wir haben da viel zu tun
und wenn man jetzt mal überlegt die
pandemie wird uns ja wirtschaftlich
zurückwerfen
und wo kommen wir da raus wo kommt china
heraus wo kommt südkorea aus wenn die
alle viel besser die masken tragen und
nicht so viel querdenker demos haben
sondern derweil schon wieder
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung dann fragt
sich wo europa landet nach dieser
pandemie das wird noch mal eine
neuordnung der region sein glaube ich
der mann rechts im bild übrigens achim
berg
der seit 2000 17 glaube ich präsident
des branchenverbandes bitkom ist aber
programmiert wenn man das wort
da hört man den frust raus einfach
darüber dass es immer wieder nur
halbherzige lockdown maßnahmen gibt
wobei man ja lockdown gar nicht sagen
kann es sind ja restriktionen sagen wir
mal recht verträglich nach ausgestaltet
sind und fakt ist ja auch ihre
fraktionen je halbherziger sie laufen
desto teurer werden sie ja das sehen wir
jetzt an den november hilfen an den
dezember helfen wir haben nur eine
stabilisierung der infektionszahlen auf
hohem niveau aber die kosten gebe heute
ihren wirklich also jeden monat 20.000
etwa 20 milliarden euro
und top und und ob und dazu viel leben
vielleicht 20 milliarden
also man sagen wir mal so es ist
natürlich auch eine art von black box
das finanzministerium und auch diese
ganzen corona helfen
als der finanzminister im september im
bundestag den haushalt für 21
eingebracht hat hat er mit 96 milliarden
euro schulden gerechnet
als dann ende november
der haushalt im bundestag
beziehungsweise im haushaltsausschuss
debattiert wurde waren es 180
also ich sage nochmal von 96 auf 180
milliarden aus griesheim ist ja noch mal
320 milliarden obendrauf das heißt
innerhalb von drei jahren aber 400
milliarden
ja aber sie sind ja dabei sind der
regierungsmitglied wenn ich das doch
ebenso müssen damit rechnen
also ich nur sagen ich finde sagen ich
glaube was frau merkel jetzt indirekt
durch die blume noch mal gesagt hat ist
wenn wir einmal richtig runter fahren
und einmal die zahlen richtig nach unten
drücken können dann ist die
nachverfolgung besser dann muss die
korona erzählt werden und dann wird es
auch nicht so teuer
und dann wird die wirtschaft auch wieder
schneller an fahrt aufnehmen wenn wir
uns heute gerade sehen die tui wurde
heute sozusagen die sind das alle
miteigentümer an der tui am größten
deutschen reiseveranstalter also ich
meine das ist nicht so verbringt aber
nicht nennen und so geht das immer
weiter immer weiter
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen also wenn
man sich diesen satz mal wirklich auf
der zunge zergehen lässt wird amin war
doch schlecht und zwar über die
unentschlossenheit deutscher politik
dass das eine und das andere auch das
ernsthaft sowas simples und ganz simpler
mechanischer mund nasen schutz der
entscheidet möglicherweise also die
frage ob ihn trägt oder nicht
entscheidet darüber wie wir durchs
nächste jahrzehnt kommt der entscheidet
über aufstieg oder fall einer ganzen
industrie nation
das ist das was da transportiert wird
und das andere ist doch die frage wenn
man das doch weiß herr lindemann
wenn sie das doch so klar sagt und für
sich erkannt hat und frau merkel ist
klug und ist physikerin versteht dass
alles was das bedeutet warum machen wir
es dann nicht warum sagen wir nicht an
warum ordnen will ich einfach mal
konsequent mund nasen schutz tragen an
einfach überall im land egal
mach es einfach ist doch jedem zuzumuten
natürlich muss man immer die
verhältnismäßigkeit darstellen sie
können auch gerne im detail darüber
reden aber ich bin mir sicher die
kanzlerin meinte wirklich das was sie
seit jahren sagt dass dir die globale
dynamik unterschätzen man muss sich nur
mal sinking anhören auf den 19 parteitag
im oktober 2017 die chinesen wollen die
welt macht erobern
bis zum jahr 2049 höher das läuft seit
jahren und wir sind zum teil muss ich
ganz klar sagen auch nach
sie fliegen nach china hin und sagen wir
möchten gerne die gleichen bedingungen
in china wie die chinesen in europa habe
ich gebe nur ein einfaches beispiel wenn
sie sich in china selbstständig machen
in der regel brauchen sie auch einen
chinesischen partner das nennt man dann
joint venture um das zu machen
die chinesen können dass hier ohne so
und da müssten jetzt auf augenhöhe den
know-how-transfer stadt mit abfällen hat
aber das gibt seit jahren genau das ist
aber nicht unser thema ich bin mir
sicher die gespräche träten aber ich
glaube einfach frau merkel hat ganz klar
gesagt dass durch die maßnahmen die in
asien ergriffen worden sind ja die
pandemie viel schneller eingedämmt
werden konnte als das hier bisher der
fall ist und es geht ja ums masken
tragen es geht natürlich auch viel um
den deutschen föderalismus also das ist
natürlich auch die bundesregierung frau
merkel sagt dass sie hat es verstanden
aber natürlich sind wir in föderaler
staat 16 ministerpräsidenten müssen das
auch umsetzen mittragen wollen alle
selber wiedergewählt werden und deswegen
hat sie noch mal gemahnt glaube ich das
ist wichtig ist dass auch in deutschland
jetzt diese partie im griff gezeigt so
ganz an die chinesische kooperation ja
vorangetrieben werden aber zuallererst
muss diese pandemie in griff bekommen
werden ja wir können ja über die masken
auch reden trotzdem ist es meines
erachtens vor allem der
überwachungsstaat dort werden die daten
permanent gespeichert volle container
heißt quarantäne
ja ist richtig auch bei ihnen herr lanz
natürlich können wir darüber diskutieren
sie müssen dass ich sie ihre mal ein
kollege der erde zu sehen war im
chinesischen staatsfernsehen der
gelegentlich bei uns auftritt und
eigentlich nie im chinesischen
staatsfernsehen dankenswerterweise der
sagte neulich fand ich sehr interessant
sagt er wenn wir einfach alle konsequent
mund nasenschutz einfacher mund nasen
schutz tragen würden
auch in der schule im alltag im bus im
supermarkt einfach überall wo es nötig
ist hätten wir heute ein komplett
anderes infektionsgeschehen werden an
einem ganz anderen punkt wir würden
nicht über weihnachten diskutieren
würden nicht über die frage diskutieren
wirtschaft rauf runter
diese grauenvolle amplitude genau das
wovor wir uns doch immer gefürchtet
hatten anfahren wieder runterfahren
anfahren das ist jetzt eingetreten
katastrophe der gleichen ecke kollege
hat natürlich auch gesagt abstand oder
maske ich spüre dass bei den gesprächen
gestern vorgestern dass man auch maske
im raum trägt aber der gleiche herr
kekulé und
andere wissenschaftler sagen ich weiß
nicht ob sie das bestätigen können dass
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man sich
draußen ansteckt 20 mal geringer ist als
drinnen ja aber ihr dann kommt natürlich
der einzelhandel auf mich zu sage ich
jetzt mal und sagt wie gehen wir damit
um wir haben keine geschäfte mehr im
kern haben sie recht ich glaube das
lässt sich auch diskutieren
ich glaube dass wir es inter schätzen an
beruflichen bereich dass man im
beruflichen bereich weniger abstand und
masken tragen eine darüber sollte noch
mal reden
trotzdem ich bleibe dabei in china
werden die daten zentral gespeichert
ich bleibe ich bleibe dabei keiner traut
sich so eine ansage zu machen
keiner traut sich eine klare ansage zu
machen vorgang also ich glaube es ist
nicht zu diskutieren ich finde dass es
umzusetzen das ist also es ist ja jetzt
erwiesen dass mit diesen schutzmaßnahmen
die zahlen in den griff bekommen werden
können und deswegen finde ich müssen wir
nicht mehr debattieren ob es ab klasse 6
oder ab klasse 7 krebs einem us
wirtschaft sondern wir müssen das
einfach mal machen und ich finde es sind
für alle furchtbare einschränkungen und
das leben ist jetzt nicht mehr so wie es
von dem jahr war wirklich für alle durch
die bank ob das familien sind ob das
allein stehen das sind ob das auf der
arbeit ist oder jetzt zu hause man
keinen job mehr hat und so weiter das
ist alles ganz schrecklich aber es ist
immer noch machbar